sie sehen die Verjüngung des ZDF
schreitet unerbittlich voran wenn auch
nur für eine Woche mein Name ist till
Reiners und ich bin heute die Vertretung
für
Oliver Welke
ja er hat leider Corona wir wünschen
gute Besserung hier aus dem Studio und
ich meine als treuer System Sklave mit
seiner heute Show ist er ja einer der
supersprayder der Pandemie Lüge
aber jetzt übertreibt das wirklich ein
bisschen oder
wirklich ganz komisch hier kannst du dir
sonst was holen offenbar da muss ich
ganz kurz mal kurz mal nachwischen in
eigener Sache nein kleiner Spaß Liebe
Olli ich vertrete dich jederzeit gern
auch wenn der affenpocken kommen oder so
ja einfach mal durchklingeln die
heute-show nach der Wahl in
Niedersachsen rot-Grün hat gewonnen
trotzdem muss man sagen eine ordentliche
Klatsche für die Regierungsparteien
14,5% für die Grünen die noch in
Umfragen bei 20 lagen die FDP ist gar
nicht drin im Landtag und die SPD war
auch nur erfolgreich weil
ja wegen weil
ans Bonus halt auch wenn sie jetzt
fragen warum ist die FDP so abgeschmiert
die machen doch super geile Politik im
Bund die wurde total missverstanden die
FDP wird oft missverstanden als eine
Partei die nun plötzlich auch links der
Mitte positioniert sei die FDP Links
oder was
das ist schon der beste Gag der Sendung
glaube ich
wie viel Kleber muss man schnüffeln wie
viel goldene Springbrunnen muss man
haben um die FDP für eine linke Partei
zu halten
die wurden abgestraft weil sie in der
Ampel ständig auf der Bremse stehen oder
wie sich selber formulieren viele
unserer Unterstützerinnen und
Unterstützer Fremde mit dieser Koalition
kein leichtes Bündnis für die FDP das
war von Anfang an klar
Ampel in Berlin fremdelt fremdeln mit
der Ampelkoalition das ist für uns ein
gewöhnungsbedürftiges und ein
schwieriges Bündnis mit Sozialdemokraten
und Grün das ist herausfordernd und die
Stimme der FDP in dieser Koalition muss
künftiger künftig noch deutlicher
erkennbar sein warum dauert es so lang
und wann kommt es so spät
sie hatten die Stimme der FDP
mir ist das jetzt schon zu deutlich
erkennbar in der Regierung die vierte
Wahlschlappe in Folge nach Saarland
Schleswig-Holstein und NRW und das
schlimme ist jetzt werden die Liberalen
richtig durchdrehen und noch mehr
Zugeständnisse von SPD und Grünen
fordern ich kann nur an die Grünen
appellieren ihr müsst jetzt die
Erwachsenen sein in dieser
dysfunktionalen ampelfamilie
sehr gut sorry mein Gott viago ist er
denn dieses rumgänge mit der FDP das tut
ihr mich gut nichts ist gefährlicher als
ein angeschossener Partei Zwerg die
holen ja jetzt nur noch oben der
Bundestagsabgeordnete Schaeffler spricht
von einem Mühlstein um den Hals der
Partei der ehemalige Parlamentarische
Staatssekretär Sattelberger schreibt bei
Twitter die Ampel sei eine politische
Vergewaltigung der FDP
ja und die FDP kann noch nicht mal ins
Frauenhaus dafür haben sie zu wenig
Frauen
es ist krass dass ich das erwähnen muss
aber vergewaltigungs Metaphern waren
schon falsch als war noch alles sagen
durfte die FDP ist die Wegfahrsperre der
Regierung es ist immer das Gleiche wenn
die FDP mal mitregiert schon zu
merkelzeiten flogen sie nach und nach
aus sieben Landtagen dann könnte was
draus lernen aber man kann ja auch
jammern wie Christian Lindner schlimm
was unser Finanzminister erleiden muss
ein regelrechter Opfergang gibt's schon
in Berliner Dom als Kirchenfenster ja
die Passion Christians seht ehe der
Harbeck dreimal kräht wird er mich
verraten und Saskia esken erhöht Hartz
IV um 50 Silberlinge
im Porsche Club wird er von seinen
arbeitgeberfreunden gegeistert für die
Erhöhung des Mindestlohns hier seht er
trägt die dornige chancenkrone wie auch
die Schuldenlast für alle unsere Sünden
er ruft freier Markt freier Markt warum
hast du mich verlassen
die Passion
Christians Ostern auf RTL Profiteure des
ampelchaos gibt es auch die AFD holt
über zehn Prozent und das mit einem
Landesverband den niemand kennt und in
dem sich alle hassen tja Niedersachsen
sind halt am Ende des Tages auch nur
Sachsen
auch die CDU sollte sich fragen wieso
sie eigentlich nicht zulegen konnte
sondern das schlechteste Wahlergebnis
seit 1959 eingefahren hat was ist gar
nicht so und nur das schlechteste
Wahlergebnis hat 1959 stimmt insofern
nicht dass wir bei der Bundestagswahl
ein schlechteres noch hatten
so ja und bei der nächsten
Bundestagswahl werden wir sogar noch
schlechter
märz muss es wissen er wollte ja schon
seit 1959 Parteivorsitzender werden
übrigens was haben völlig märz und Greta
Thunberg gemeinsam ja sie werden beide
nie Bundeskanzler aber das ist noch
nicht alles in der ARD sagt Greta
thünenberg wenn die Atomkraftwerke schon
laufen wäre es ein Fehler sie
abzuschalten und sich der Kohle
zuzuwenden
okay Greta thünenberg will AKWs
weiterlaufen lassen ja wie die meisten
wird auch sie im Alter immer
konservativer
noch ein zwei Jahre dann schreibt es im
Buch mit Peter Hahne
die nächste mammutbaustelle der
Regierung ist auf jeden Fall die
Energiekrise wir müssen alle 20% Gas
einsparen nur so lässt sich die ganz
große Rezession noch verhindern hätte
man ahnen müssen dass uns die
Abhängigkeit von Russland irgendwann um
die Ohren fliegt sagt nicht ich sondern
dieser putinexperte was ist mit den
Energielieferungen denn auch die nutzt
der russische Präsident als Waffe ich
war mir
immer sicher dass er das tun würde
ja
er hat es schon immer gewusst aber er
wollte dass wir da selber drauf kommen
währenddessen zerfleischen sich harberg
und Lindner monatelang wegen gasumlage
und AKW Laufzeiten seit Kriegsbeginn ist
klar Energie wird teurer und das trifft
Arme Haushalte am härtesten jetzt musste
eine Expertenkommission kurz vor knapp
überlegen wie kann man staatliche Hilfen
gerecht verteilen oder das war denen
doch das Wichtigste das mit der
Gerechtigkeit oder und unsere erste
Priorität im Einklang mit dem Auftrag
der Bundesregierung war schnell zu sein
ja und die Aufgabe war ja auch ganz
einfach
niemand soll frieren Arme müssen stärker
entlastet werden als reiche aber nicht
zu doll denn die Leute sollen trotzdem
Gas sparen und alle drei ampelparteien
müssen damit leben können und dafür habt
er ein Wochenende Zeit go
dafür ist das Ergebnis gar nicht
schlecht der Staat erstattet die
Abschlagszahlung für dezember ab März
sind 80% des vorjahresverbrauchs
gedeckelt gerecht ist das alles
überhaupt nicht denn der Mieter in einem
Mehrfamilienhaus soll mit knapp 1.200
Euro entlastet werden die Besitzerin
einer Villa mit Pool mit über 9000 warum
welche dieser drei Parteien könnten
Interesse haben das nicht nur Bedürftige
was kommen sondern auch reiche
ich komme nicht drauf
dabei hätte es eine einfache und faire
Lösung gegeben bis zu einer gewissen
Einkommensgrenze erhalten alle eine
Einmalzahlung wer mehr verbraucht zahlt
selber geht aber nicht sagt Christian
Lindner denn dafür müssen Steuernummer
und IBAN zusammengebracht werden das
dauert mal eben 18 Monate diese ganzen
Daten zusammenzubauen
18 Monate überlegen Sie mal das erlebt
Christian Lindner vielleicht gar nicht
mehr als Minister
Leute die sich auskennen sagen übrigens
das Argument ist nur vorgeschoben
trotzdem arbeitet die Regierung jetzt
mit Hochdruck an einer Lösung
von den Machern von wir wissen nicht wer
in diesem Land geimpft ist und wie oft
und Tempolimit geht nicht weil wir haben
zu wenig Schilder kommt jetzt das
Megaprojekt die Verknüpfung von Steuer
ID und Kontonummer das haben bisher nur
Länder wie Österreich geschafft wir
haben zwar das Auto erfunden die Rakete
und den Computer aber zwei Nummern
verknüpfen die eine unterschiedliche
Anzahl an Ziffern haben wow unter Berlin
wird dafür ein gigantischer
Teilchenbeschleuniger gebaut von der
einen Seite wird die Steuernummer
losgeschickt und prallt im Collider mit
der Kontonummer zusammen mit etwas Glück
erleben wir dann in wenigen Jahren die
Geburt einer Einmalzahlung die
Verknüpfung von Steuer ID und
Kontonummer wenn das möglich ist
schaffen wir es vielleicht auch dass man
seine Reservierung auch im Ersatzzug
behält wenn der ICE mal wieder ausfällt
wir freuen uns drauf
aber die hohen Energiepreise werden
leider nicht so schnell verschwinden
dazu waren jetzt viele Experten schon
vor Strom Ausfällen ein wirklich langer
bundesweiter Blackout ist zwar sehr
unwahrscheinlich aber auch nicht
auszuschließen was dann zu tun ist weiß
dieser Flagge
dieser Flagge will ihrer Familie den
Ernst der Lage klar machen der Blackout
ist eine reale Gefahr auf die man sich
vorbereiten muss
das ist kein Spaß mehr ihr glaubt gar
nicht was da alles dranhängt an dieser
ganzen Stromversorgung kein elektrisches
Licht keine Heizung kein fließend Wasser
wir können auch nicht mal mehr dann aufs
Klo gehen naja also wir können schon
dann ein bisschen aber irgendwann halt
nicht mehr Marius
Marius Schatz würdest du bitte zuhören
ja
wir können dann auch nicht mehr aufs Klo
gehen gehe ich halt den Garten du kannst
dann auch nicht mehr dein Handy aufladen
na und ich habe eine Powerbank wie schön
für dich der WLAN-Router ist dann auch
aus
alle Experten raten Vorräte also Wasser
und Essen für zwei Wochen immer im Haus
zu haben es macht auch durchaus Sinn
muss ja ein bisschen halten damit
das ist jetzt nicht euer Ernst oder
dieser Flagge hat die Schnauze
voll beschließt mit ihrer Ignoranten
Familie ein Wochenende ohne Strom
realistisch zu simulieren
ganz wichtig natürlich Trinkwasser mein
Tipp lassen Sie einfach Ihre Badewanne
mit frischem Wasser volllaufen das macht
mindestens 200 Liter
was
nach nur zehn Minuten Blackout lebt
Familie Flagge wie einst ihre Vorfahren
in der Steinzeit alte Instinkte setzen
wieder ein sogar die Sprache degeneriert
Fleisch gut
woher ist das hatten wir das noch
ja ja
gute Nachrichten die Bank ist von
nebenan haben eine bofrost-lieferung
bekommen
die holen wir
uns
der Blackout gott steh uns allen bei
wir haben gesagt die sollen meinen
Lieblingswitz erzählen was mache ich
gerne also kommen ein Pferd Jeff Bezos
und der Papst in eine Bar sagt der
Barkeeper abonnier endlich denn
verkackten heute schon
Kanal also geht doch